how do you speak truth to power when you
work in an environment where speaking
truth to power can get you fired or
could get you in trouble one of the
reasons that happens is not because
we're necessarily speaking truth to
power it's the manner in which we do it
we usually do it as a complaint or we do
it as an aggressive question and we also
do without empathy one of the most
important things to do is have empathy
for the people who we work for we don't
know what their story is we don't know
what kind of pressure they're under we
don't know if they're operating from a
point of fear and so when we come in
guns a-blazing their walls are gonna go
up because we're aggressive or we're
perceived as aggressive so if you can
maintain empathy and some curiosity and
work hard to spend the time to build a
relationship with with that person in
that authority position so they
understand that we want to see them
succeed and I want to ask you some
questions because if you can ask these
questions hi I can be more successful
which is gonna help you be more
successful or to say things like are you
okay or to say things like hey you would
really harsh to us on the meeting today
I just want to check in with you is
everything okay these are little things
we can do to think about them as human
beings rather than oppressors and to
operate with as much empathy and
curiosity as possible and hopefully
build that relationship so they see us
as trust and trusting and amazingly
they'll probably open up and you'll
learn a lot more so that that works
[Music]